time moving adiabatically from a known case to the case of interest but since there are no classical parameters being
passed and no variational wave function how do you update your state from one pass at the hamiltonian to the next well
they add a bias feel to the hamiltonian whatever the lowest energy state from the previous run they add a term in the
hamiltonian to the bias the state in favor of that so why is this experiment of
Interest well first of all this is a new approach that could be applied more generally to other optimization problems
but in this case they applied it to an ising spin glass problem as we discussed previously many combinatorial
optimization problems can be reformulated as solving for low energy states of ising hamiltonians the ising
model is a series of microscopic spins distributed on an array the model can be used to describe a spin glass in which
the magnetization is disordered basically the little magnetic moments are oriented randomly in the array and
why did we think this would work well we already sort of covered how we are combating two typical issues found in
variational algorithms when we covered the definitions of the paper but to summarize the algorithm they are
proposing speeds up the evolution to reduce the circuit depth while also suppressing non-adiabatic transitions
furthermore it does not rely on any classical optimization routine which can be an issue leading to Barren
plateaus and getting stuck at local Minima lastly the authors also make sure to align the interactions in the problem
hamiltonian with the hardware connectivity in the real qpu which is always very important lastly how does this work so
like I said there are no classical optimizers being used here like there often is in iterative Quantum algorithms
instead by feeding the solution from each iteration into to the input for the next one the bias field digitized
Quantum optimization algorithm incrementally refines the ground state bringing it closer and closer to the
final evolved State and combined with counter adiabatic protocols we can do this even with short depth Quantum
circuits that should run smoothly on noisy Hardware so when the experiment was performed the authors chose to run the
algorithm on the 127 Cubit IBM quantum computer Brisbane here the author showed
the eth ization of the optimization algorithm for a nearest neighbor randomly generated spin glass instance
over 100 cubits they compare ideal simulation results from dcq and bf dcq
as well as the experimental result and they also show a result from a classical solver called goobi as a reference now
with just 10 iterations BF dcq provides a drastic enhancement compared to
dcq although the experimental result is a bit different than the ideal result due to noise the performance is still
better than the ideal dcq this shows that there's still a lot of excellent progress being made with
regards to Quantum optimization and good results are being reported on over 100 cubits for one of the first
times last but not least is a very interesting paper exploring mRNA structure prediction from our friends at
madna Pharmaceuticals and it's called mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers to begin if you like me still haven't taken a biology course in a few years you can refresh yourself on what
mRNA is messenger RNA is a type of RNA involved in protein synthesis it
basically reads instructions given by DNA the secondary structure of mRNA is more or less how the chain is folded and
the RNA secondary structure prediction proc problem is the problem of finding the most stable folding of the sequence
of bases of nucleotides that make up DNA and RNA that would be c g u and a this
image here shows some of the common folding structures found in mRNA each color highlighting here shows a
different secondary structure but the exact characteristics for what makes one of these structures more favorable over
another isn't well understood all we can do is figure out which which one has the lowest free energy compared to the
unfolded state and that's where quantum computers step in so why are mRNA secondary structures
important well accurate prediction of them is actually crucial and not only understanding DNA and our genes but also
for Designing RNA based Therapeutics like the covid-19 vaccine there is reason to believe that the approach in
this paper would work because this has long been known to be a formidable optimiz ation problem for classical
computers due to the vast number of possible configurations and for some configurations it's actually known to be
an NP complete problem however on a quantum computer we can formulate the secondary structure prediction as a
binary optimization problem something we know how to handle furthermore there has been evidence in the literature already
of accurate RNA prediction on small scale Quantum devices and Quantum simulators so the obvious question is
would this work on larger Hardware the experiment is done by using something called the conditional value
at risk variational Quantum igen solver which is a modification to the traditional vqe algorithm and is
expected to achieve better convergence this plot shows the distribution of measurement
probabilities of the sample bit strings with the corresponding energies for 42
nucleotide 80 Cubit instance here the bit strings symbolize pairings of the
nucleotides it illustrates that the lowest energy bit string has an energy value ofus 140 which matches the lowest
energy bit strength found by the comparative classical solver so that's great and this is the optimal folded
structure of that nucleotide chain based on the lowest energy bit string the hardware has
found and with that we have reached the conclusion of this episode now my aim here was not to overwhelm you with
details from different research papers like I said I simply wanted to give you an all enough context understand what
Cutting Edge work in the field looks like right now the hope is that this will get some gears turning in
everybody's head and that by seeing how others are approaching problems you will be able to make connections and have the
confidence to attempt new Quantum experiments that you might not have before and hey maybe some of those won't
pan out and that's fine that's why this is research going forward remember that the types of problems that we are
interested in can be grouped by either methodology or by subject and we have laid out the ones that we believe to be